back in this country we want to tell you
about an escalation in the political
fight over immigration dozens of
apparent migrants landed by Charter
flight on a Rocky island in the Atlantic
Martha's Vineyard Massachusetts this was
yesterday afternoon they arrived as part
of what governor Ron DeSantis calls a
relocation program many did not know
where they were going and local
officials on the island were not given
any advance notice of the flight's
arrival Nick Giovanni of our Boston
station WBZ is in Woods Hole that's just
across the water from Martha's Vineyard
in Massachusetts uh Nick good morning
Tony good morning to you this is one of
the ferry terminals here on Cape Cod
that takes passengers to Martha's
Vineyard and it is there this morning
where those migrants are waking up in at
least two shelters that we know of
following an island-wide response to
their arrival
volunteers on Martha's Vineyard found
themselves scrambling to find shelter
food water and other services to
accommodate the unforeseen arrival of 50
migrants including the elderly and
children flown there as part of a
relocation plan originated by Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis the Martha's
Junior Community Services had 50 people
sort of literally walk up to their front
door Witnesses say the group wandered
some three miles from the airport into
Edgartown once in town the migrants were
met by volunteers who brought them to a
high school where they were fed and
later transported by school bus to a
church to stay for the night authorities
sent out urgent pleas on social media
asking for volunteers to help with an
urgent humanitarian situation Barbara
Rush worked into the night helping the
families at St Andrews Episcopal Church
from what we found out by talking to the
people there originally from Venezuela
they were flown here
um we're not sure
um what what plane brought them here or
how they got on a plane to hear
volunteers said they were told by some
of the migrants they did not know where
they were but we're told they would be
given housing and jobs a statement from
a DeSantis spokesperson read in part
Massachusetts New York and California
will better facilitate the care of these
individuals who they have invited into
our country by incentivizing illegal
immigration through their designation as
sanctuary States
since the spring Republican governors in
Texas and Arizona have transported
several thousand migrants and Asylum
Seekers to New York Chicago and
Washington D.C all cities with
Democratic Mayors yet unlike those major
cities these arrivals aren't met with
migrant resources and services like
immigrations courts where their Asylum
cases can be heard immigrants who were
told that they would be greeted here
with a place to stay and with jobs
Massachusetts state representative Dylan
Fernandez arrived on the island
Wednesday and called the move by the
DeSantis government to transport
migrants there with seemingly no
coordination quote evil they're using
children as political pawns
but the Island community has really
rallied together
in addition to fruit and shelter
migrants were also tested for covid and
we're all negative we're told now as for
Massachusetts governor Charlie Baker
who's also a republican his office told
us the state will continue to support
the short-term Sheltering Services
provided to those migrants reporting
from Woods Hole Cape Cod Massachusetts
Nick Giovanni Tony back to you in New
York
uh Nick Giovanni for us from WBZ there
are Partners in Massachusetts a story
unlike any I'm sure you or your stations
ever covered uh thank you very much this
has not happened in this way before
right there's been a crisis at the
border for multiple decades Congress
multiple presidents have not solved that
crisis there's been busing to Chicago to
D.C to New York the difference here is
that Martha's Vineyard is a tiny island
of 15 000 people without an ice Court
without an infrastructure that can
handle an influx like this without
Social Services in place let alone on
late notice yeah late notice yeah like
no notice no notice yeah it's just you
know ultimately they're probably gonna
end up in Boston uh but you know it's
it's a change that's why we call it an
escalation off the top this is a shift
in strategy I thought the word inhumane
was a good good one to use in this
particular case so people don't know
where they're going the people that are
there don't know you're coming right
it's good to see though that they're
being welcomed and that people are
trying to help them yeah right you're
right volunteers exactly I've been to
Martha's Vineyard many times it's a
great great place place but at least
give people some notice so they can
prepare part of this best known for
where they shot Jaws but it's not the
end of the story this is going to
continue I think for sure